hey everyone welcome thanks for tuning
in
as you guys know this is our six hundred
and sixty sixth episode and I have been
synthesizing the most profound things
that I've learned in the last couple of
years and it all really comes down to
one thing all ancient spirituality all
cutting-edge science comes to one thing
that's the evolution of consciousness
all of the most important metaphysical
questions that exist Jake thanks for
your question I'll address that I will
in question was about if this is a
computed game of sorts we'll definitely
get there all of the most important
metaphysical inquiries about the true
nature of reality come down to the
evolution of consciousness we as one
cohesive whole unbounded infinite whole
are exploring infinity so we're gonna
refer to that as a source okay we're
gonna call that source this infinite
unbounded whole and we are exploring
infinity and if you'd like to visualize
this you can visualize this like the
source light splitting through a prism
and becoming the visible light spectrum
you may have seen that in the images
that we've recently been posting
this is the absolute hardest thing that
I've ever done is piece together all of
this content across everything I've
learned the last couple of years into a
what I'm calling a digital Sistine
Chapel the world has a lot of noise and
so I would really like to make something
of great signal that can last the test
of time that brings people a lot of
value that people can continue building
on top of over time so that idea of us
all being an unbounded infinite hole
called source exploring infinity and us
being a this being a permutation of that
a combinatoric if you will now this
completely depends I'm going to speak to
this on a scientific level as well
because it's very important that we get
to the understanding of this on not only
a non dual spiritual level but also on a
scientific level so on a scientific
level what I believe is going to be the
most important one of the most important
fields of the 21st century is called
evolutionary psychology of course along
with artificial intelligence and there's
going to be more that emerges but
evolutionary psychology is what you
could call this scientifically and it's
basically what you can look back 5,000
years and you can find spiritualists in
India and many other parts of the world
that have been studying these interior
states of consciousness so now science
has a term
or evolutionary psychology and we're
studying it and very generally speaking
the evolution of consciousness has been
from a deep time perspective from that
source point which you could call the
Big Bang or you could call God or you
could call all that is or you could call
basically any of those up until the
evolution of life somewhere around 4
billion years ago let's say and then
that process of what is abiogenesis the
initial formulation of life and
everything that it's picked up over
these billions of years going from
single-cell organisms to multi cell
organisms to building up this nervous
system and all of the experiences that
we've been like a chain epigenetically
building up until this point that's why
you when you're born already basically
have a tremendous amount of a priori
biological and cognitive infrastructures
already built within you now what we
could call this evolution is that your
ability to go from egoic perceptual
infrastructure to slowly evolved beyond
ego right evolutionary psychology and
spirituality are both pointing the same
thing we evolved beyond ego and this
next what you could call level
is something along the lines of a social
or an ethno style perception so all of a
sudden we realize that ok well I'm
evolving beyond my ego and I can now
perspective take I now know how to get
behind someone else's eyes I know how to
I know how to empathize better and ethno
meaning that ok now I associate myself
maybe with my state
or maybe with my country so that's an
evolution I'm speaking very generally
here we could definitely get into more
of the nitty-gritty nuances especially
with people like jean piaget that have
been literally studying this there are
many other incredible psychologists that
have been studying this but I'm giving
you at a very very very abstracted level
rather than getting into the nitty
gritty details the next one is having a
world centric consciousness so you move
beyond just being social or ethno to
world centric all of a sudden you're
realizing that humans are one species
out of ten million other species you're
realizing that every single breath of
air that you take in you're literally
summoning the photosynthesis that has
been happening by phytoplankton and
trees on the planet every breath of air
and your exhale of co2 goes directly
back to them and the probe and the cycle
of photosynthesis continues so you're
really starting to get this world
centric perspective right you can tell
we're embedding both science here with
things like photosynthesis and
evolutionary psychology but we're also
talking about this very spiritually as
well as the consciousness becomes less
egocentric it becomes acknowledging the
interconnectedness the depth of the
interconnectedness which many indigenous
wisdoms across the planet have been
communicating for the longest time
okay so we've gone to this world centric
perspective now this is kind of the this
is where evolutionary psychology kind of
is is trying to figure out how to get to
the next levels we call this
transpersonal psychology going beyond
just your personal self right so we had
a little bit of that in the world
centric with understanding the
interconnectedness but are we really
actually feeling the truth of being the
photosynthesis are we feeling the truth
of being the phytoplankton
in the tree and in the ancient spiritual
lineages of metaphysics again this is
not specific to one in Hinduism we have
Advaita Vedanta
in Buddhism we have Zen in zouk chen in
christianity we have Gnosticism in
judaism we have the kabbalah and
hasidism and in islam we have Sufism so
we literally have and this isn't even to
include west-african vodoun
or this isn't even including the the
practices at sweat lodges in the native
americans so there's many many many
ancient spiritual traditions that have
gone beyond the personal transpersonal
to feel the true interconnectedness of
the unbounded infinite whole that we all
collectively are and that we are all
collectively evolving as a really great
word for this is metamorphosis it's such
an important word metamorphosis and
johann wolfgang von goethe was a crucial
pillar and understanding metamorphosis a
huge studier of it and that's basically
what the evolution of consciousness is
it is metamorphosis ok back to these
transpersonal states thank you everyone
for tuning in and for all these comments
we'll definitely get to addressing what
you've been asking so this idea of going
beyond the personal ultimately what we
want to achieve is what is called non
dual states of consciousness right these
studies of the interior of consciousness
of my own personal experience what does
it mean to be non dual what does it mean
for me to feel like I'm everything all
the time that's constantly evolving that
there is no more this line of separation
between myself and the exterior between
the Interior and the XD
yet at the same time it's also beautiful
to acknowledge what the West has brought
forth which is this this individuation
of consciousness that you are the
beautiful unique artistic expression
that is in this collective symphony okay
so we have we can carry both of these at
the same time this beauty of this
unbounded infinite whole at the same
time that we carry the beauty of me be
in you and all of us individuation of
own unique artistic expression of
consciousness so we all contribute as a
unique puzzle piece to the symphony
that's unfolding so we have that
Symphony analogy and all of the unique
pieces of the symphony that is also all
of our individual gifts okay so this
these feelings whatever path you end up
taking to be able to experience on the
interior this non dual experience of
reality and merging that together with
your unique individual expression
there's several layers before non-dual
there's things like nature mysticism
like we were talking about with feeling
the actual photosynthesis that's
happening or feeling the actual trees or
the mountains but then there's deity
mysticism and then there's formless
mysticism and so these are things called
like the psychic being or the the the
the subtle being the causal being and
then the non-dual being but we go beyond
even that we go beyond even that in
evolutionary consciousness and
transpersonal psychology in evolutionary
psychology we go beyond that because now
what all of the great mystics of the
last thousands of years have never been
able to intuit because they never had
computers we now discovered our ability
to create semiconductors and run these
computations and as you can tell our
obsession or channels called simulation
that we are now at an unprecedented
level of computational capacity and
we're just about 70 years or so really
into this this information age that all
of these great sages and mystics of the
past would have never been able to
intuit
which is simulation theory we had a
question earlier about if we're all in a
game so now we have to synthesize not
only ancient spirituality so the past
evolutionary psychology but we have to
synthesize in artificial intelligence
and simulation theory and you can tell
that by having this these devices that
are incredibly excellent at recording
and then showing us what we've recorded
we can now we're getting closer and
closer to these indistinguishable
virtual worlds we're getting super super
on the way from from pong to
indistinguishable virtual worlds in half
a lifetime nuts and what that's doing is
that it's creating this layer this
visual layer that we look at and that we
build and that we begin seeing oh wow
okay I think we get it now we get what
we did we get what we are we're starting
to get it more and more and if you think
about it like that we ask source made
this reality for us to evolve go through
the process of metamorphosis and for us
to evolve our consciousness and we
embedded very specific things in this
exploration for us to awaken and
remember for example you take things
like plant medicines and you realize
that when you take plant medicines that
you become all that is okay that's a
hilarious feature that we embedded and
so now we were being titrated a dose of
remembering slow
over time as we evolved and awakened to
the true nature of this reality and what
these what these virtual worlds are
showing us this indistinguishable
virtual worlds is that we ourselves are
approaching a singularity point and
again these ancient spirituality has
passed and have simulation theory and
computers to be able to in virtual
worlds to be able to tell these things
ok so what does that mean then are we
ourselves approaching a singularity
point to create an aural Boros a full
circle where we ourselves continue the
cycle of the evolution of consciousness
if we are truly source exploring
infinity there is much more infinity to
explore and that there is more game for
us to play and that we are in the
process of figuring out how to embed
even more complicated fun exploratory
codes in these next iterations that we
go through as they say Turtles all the
way down in respect to 5 Mao DMT we can
say toads all the way up so in essence
it is all the evolution of consciousness
metaphysics the nature of reality points
to metamorphosis evolutionary psychology
is understanding this transpersonal
psychology is understanding this you
synthesize the non-dual states of
consciousness you synthesize that with
scientifically what we are discovering
as children emerge from egocentric to
ethnocentric and social centric to world
centric to these transpersonal states of
consciousness so this is the big
synthesis you have to synthesize
simulation theory with those things and
then you really start getting who we are
where we're going and what the true
nature of this reality really is and you
have to really embody if the embody the
feeling of non-duality which requires
silence
that's the key leverage silence to quiet
the monkey mind rather than being a
laborer in a thought Factory become the
witness become the source become the sky
rather than attaching yourself to the
clouds of a version and of craving be
the sky that non-dual sky that witness
the more that we quiet our minds the
more we tap into this evolutionary
process that's pulling that's pulling
it's coming down into us and pulling us
up to our next evolutionary layers
because man is a transitional being a
Sri Aurobindo
ken wilber and so many of the other
greats have been figuring out and trying
to communicate we are a transitionary
being and so leverage that silence and
you'll really beautifully see that
silence be able to dissolve other
people's negativity you can kind of tell
sometimes there's like this adverse
force that comes either at you or
through other people at you and if you
stay silent equal an economist a mobile
cellular immobility when you stay that
way you dissolve the negative vibration
that's there it's very beautiful
so that silence will help you evolve
your consciousness will help you get to
the transpersonal states of
consciousness but we really have to get
to even the world centric states of
consciousness before we get to
and those transpersonal states of
consciousness so ask yourselves that
these big questions who are we why are
we here where are we going and how do we
synthesize ancient spirituality non-dual
wisdom with evolutionary psychology and
modernity of studying consciousness and
also of simulation theory and where we
are going with that
I'm calling this for this big project
I'm calling this the metamorphosis
theory of everything that's what it's
being called and it'll be out in a
couple of months in its full detail I'm
trying to make this really like that
digital Sistine Chapel where it's really
beautifully disseminated via art and
it's distilled via art and that it can
last the test of time and people can
really build on top of and find great
value in it so it's taking me a while to
put all these codes together but that's
it that's it everyone I love you very
much I really appreciate everybody
that's tuning in to this channel and
that cares about literally this channel
right this channel and that cares about
the biggest questions thank you for
caring about the biggest questions thank
you for caring about evolving our
individual consciousnesses and this
collective consciousness to the next
levels i love you very much
thanks everyone and happy episode number
666 it's a very celebratory episode and
on none other than the evolution of
consciousness
you